the fact that in mathematical deduction
you are never it isn't does not seem to
be possible and so let's not take it as
an axiom rather than try to prove it or
not that you're ever actually a hundred
percent sure that every step in your
proof is correct
and that's obviously true when people
first come up with say a suggested
solution to the poncare conjecture or
something like that
or when andy wiles came up with um his
proofs that among other things
established from us last theorem
um
it was very very clear at the time that
there was a non-zero probability that
there was a mistake somewhere that it
was wrong
mathematicians tend to
um uh
treat these results as though they
almost for lack of a better way to
undergo a phase transition that after
people have gone over them enough
that yeah now we're sure of them and
we're going to treat them as 100 percent
i'm ironclad
holy writ
what important in fact of course that's
never what happens is rather the set of
people are always it's a
sarcastic process by which it comes to
greater and greater
confidence in the results may i
interject
please please please sure do that
as much as you possibly can otherwise i
have a tendency to open loop yeah i'd
i'd like to make this i'd like to make
this clear for the audience generally
when a mathematician proves something
you don't go through
what you may learn in a logic course
which is you state the axioms then you
have some rules of inference like modus
ponens and then you go step one is a
step two step three step four step five
that's actually extremely tedious even
to prove the most simple theorems now
this can be done on a computer
but well this can be done on a computer
so i don't think
professor you're talking about that
actually even then because
this is for example uh the proofs of the
four color map theorem which is the
first one that was done on a
computer it's actually a somewhat
controversial um issue in practicing
mathematics as well as philosophy of
mathematics
is
first of all is it a proof if human
beings can't understand it but even more
to the point you now have to validate
the actual code the program that's being
used and that can never be done to a
hundred percent
so you can't ever quite i don't think
there's actually anybody has tried to
formally have a no-go theorem that
proves this
um which is an interesting idea but as a
matter of practice it there's always
some place that you need to simply say
well it's been vetted it's good enough
let's run with it and not scrutinize us
anymore
your operating system computer programs
cosmic ray can hit
a transistor and it can make a
fluctuation so you can think that's
validated by computer
even then you're not completely
100 sure now what do mathematicians say
in response to what you're saying
because it's as if you're undermining
the entire validity of their existence
oh um well they say that very very
quickly you get to the the situation
where the probability that it's um
actually mistaken
it get the more it gets scrutinized the
lower that probability becomes formally
though because informally you can say
that can you say well we believe with a
99.58
certainty in fermat's last theorem's
proof for example
they never actually do that this is all
a matter of heuristics the sociology of
the field
um the natural so one of the ways of
viewing the motivation for the noisy
deductive reasoning stuff
is that um you can imagine trying to
actually formalize that say there is a
stochastic process
um you can imagine just where we are
what's called iid so just independent
identically distributed
i'm doing samples of whether
so you can imagine a very very simple
model where here is a hypothesis
a proposed theorem
and that you are many times
independently testing with a simple bit
flip um is this actually true or not
and if you keep getting those flips that
um keep coming up saying true true true
true and they're all independent
then according to many things like
bayesian reasoning and so on and so
forth it depends upon what are called
your prior probabilities
what's called your posterior probability
that actually is true given the data
that it's been tested now a thousand
times now a hundred thousand times now a
million times
the probability that's wrong as the
number of tests the number of different
people who have checked it over
keeps growing
that probably of error shrinks as the
number of checks grows
it's actually you can make a very very
simple model where it's formally
identical
to the proposition that the sun will
rise tomorrow
you personally um kurt have seen the sun
rise i don't know a couple of thousand
times
if we may be
squinting our definition of what it
means for you personally to see it rise
we could allow you to build to pull upon
social media or just general media and
so on and say it's even tens of
thousands
so something called laplace's law of
succession this goes back to simone
laplace
where he uses very very simple bayesian
reasoning he was actually the first
person to
really use bayesian reasoning bayes
didn't really use it essentially
um so laplace used it to uh estimate
trajectories of plants or whatnot but in
any case there's something called
laplace's law of succession
which says that if you have seen it um
arise
a thousand times and you've never seen
it fail to rise
then under a very reasonable choice for
what's called the prior probability you
would expect you would assign the
expected chance of it rising tomorrow
is a thousand and one divided by a
thousand and two
but that's not the same thing as one
so you can build a very very simple um a
model of what mathematicians are doing
which is that every time a new
mathematician takes a new look at the
proposed proof
that it's just like i'm having the sun
do another test of whether the sun's
rising
and just like every time you see the sun
rise from one day to the next you get
more and more confident that yep the sun
will also rise tomorrow
mathematicians every time they do a new
um
test of having somebody scrutinize it
and coming up and saying yep looks
legitimate to me
you can say there's a greater
probability that the next mathematician
will come to that same conclusion
but in both cases you'll never actually
achieve
a notion
anything like whether you can even
define it as saying it is true 100
and so you can build simple mathematic
models of the mathematical process along
those lines and doing that you can
actually justify some common mathematics
heuristics
mathematical reason is for example if
you
um are
still in the stage where you're trying
to ascertain whether you think a
proposition a proposed theorem is true
if
it as a mathematician or a theoretician
in any field
if there are what you might view as
multiple independent lines of reasoning
all of which say that that proposition
is true
versus there only being one
when there's multiple independent ones
you are going to assign higher
probability to being true than not being
true
that's as a matter of
social practice humans do that
and by using this model of mathematical
reasoning you can actually say guess
what that's actually formally
justifiable
using some of the rules of bayesian
reasoning
so one thing one can do
is take this approach to what
mathematicians actually do
and actually
establish that some of the heuristics
that mathematicians engage in are
actually legitimate
but where things become much more
interesting to me at least personally
is if you say along the spirit that well
that's weak in the parallel line
postulate and look guess what comes out
non-euclidean geometry in all of its
riches
let's weaken the postulate the continuum
hypothesis and guess what what comes up
is all different kinds of mathematical
logics and so on so forth
we can say let's weaken the hypothesis
that mathematics
itself is in some sense external to
humans
the humans are discovering it and that
it mathematics
is ironclad with every step being
following from a previous step
in a deterministic manner instead let's
weaken that and assume that it's not
just mathematicians
who are sarcastic prophecies but in some
sense that which they are engaging with
mathematics itself
the underpinnings of our physical
reality if you are going to adopt a max
chegmark's view
of what physics is that's just
mathematics
that it itself is inherently a
stochastic process
that the quadratic equation it's not
just human mathematicians
whose confidence in the quadratic
equation
is um never 100
that actually the quadratic equation
itself
in a if you're to adopt an almost plot
pattern this view of mathematics this
external thing
that humanity is trying to get its hands
around
that it itself also is not 100 true but
is only squishy
what are the consequences
and that's what we're wrestling with in
that body of work
so professor
you mentioned that
you use the phrase for a reasonable
choice of priors
um so how does one
how do you because so here's what i'm
thinking the priors in some sense when
you're doing bayesian reasoning it
doesn't matter what matters is that you
update it in accordance to a certain
model so then you want your posteriors
to be a certain amount like let's say
you want to be 99 certain of a certain
fact is it not true that you can then
change your priors so like
let me figure out how to phrase this
you're spot on the prior essentially
essentially you can always change the
priors to give you any posterior
probability that you want you can
reverse the equation and then correct
okay
you're correct and that's related to the
no free lunch theorems
um another way of phrasing this is why
sociologically
bayesian reasoning fell into very ill
repute
around the beginning of the 20th century
and that's why i'm a fisher
and other fellow travelers they came up
with things like um
hypothesis testing
confidence intervals all that kind of
stuff
what's called sampling theory statistics
um became ascendant and bayesian
reasoning fell into disrepute because
people misused it by choosing priors
that were leading to
results that kept coming up wrong and
bayesian reasoning is a matter of
garbage in garbage out
to push it even further
there is no way
that anybody's even imagined that you
can somehow prove
what the priors
are what they should be how you should
reason
there are
heuristics people like to use what's
called uninformative priors what are
called jeffrey's priors
ed jane's in his book the logic of
science and many of his
i use the phrase fellow travelers
they will try to say that your priors
that it behooves you to choose priors
that accurately
reflect the precise forms of ignorance
that you have about assist
um
that's nice seems reasonable they've not
proven that injunction
it's just they're taking it almost as a
feature of good practice
um
one might dispute it and even if one
does not dispute it
it's only going to get you so far there
are many scenarios where just what you
might mean by
quantifying my ignorance as a prior is
not at all clear
um so yeah so we are in a certain sense
the no fee lunge theorems are saying
this
by um
one way of to view
what are their contents is that
if i have any particular reasoning
algorithm be it in say the machine
learning algorithms
or optimization algorithms evolution
itself any of which is a search
algorithm
and if i find that of my two algorithms
a and b
that for one set of priors a
outperforms b
so it's going to make more accurate
predictions about whether the sun will
rise tomorrow or what have you
that foreign for there is always going
to be just as many priors
for which b beats right okay way of
taking your intuition and
not only quantifying your intuition
but also
um
elaborating that it's more than just one
teeny little squirrely if you want to be
a naysaying
um annoyance you can find a
counterexample it's saying no it's not
just that there's one prior in which the
conclusion that you want to reach
is counterfeited
rather there's just as many in which
that conclusion is wrong as which there
are in which it is correct
when you say just as much more than just
a single one when you say just as many
you mean in terms of that
in the low freelance
yes
exactly so it's a um
the no free lunch theorems are stated in
the following way they say that if i
take a
in the scenarios to which they apply you
can have a
a prior itself um
you can define a probability
distribution over priors
and you can say let's let's just
mathematically it's a mathematical trick
say there's a uniform distribution over
priors
then i can say that on average where i'm
averaging over that distribution over
priors
any two algorithms perform the same
so that means that if i find one
particular set of priors
whose measure
under that uniform distribution is such
that it
that algorithm beats a a beats b
under that set of priors
then there's another set which has equal
measure under this uniform distribution
so you yes it's the same number but
number is being defined very precisely
in terms of a
probability distribution it's it's we're
talking about infinite spaces as a thing
so it's not just counting oh there's
three priors for which a beats b and
three priors which b beats a
it means the size of the set of um
in a volume sense by which a beats b is
the same as which b beats a